so do you want to look at the whole game
or like to start specifically with the
endgame okay so so here I think you you
said that you wanted to push the pawn
yes was that here okay so actually this
would not have been as effective as I
think you're giving it credit for
because right next to me if I'm moving
right and that's what you were
referencing and the problem is the spot
is not a liability
it looks intimidating but your king is
now tied down to it so in the end game
you want to be very careful about
pushing your pawns and making moves that
look intimidating because weaknesses are
permanence basically there's nothing to
defend them with and so after king g5 he
can also trade a pair of Brooks and that
lessens the load on his King and this is
also like a less good spot for me yes
earlier like got my rocks into a better
spot once the trade was made right
exactly and actually your move King e6
was fine and now he walked right into
this check and this was the critical
position that I wanted to to unpack now
if you look at this King this which you
thought this move you thought was
checkmate is not checkmate because his
real contesta square but yes what can
you notice about all of the squares on
the fourth-ranked if you put a rook on
any of the squares on the fourth-ranked
are there other than d4 what what is
that what happens it's a free rook and
check me oh and check me right so and
checkmate so imagine you your rook
because now he makes it not to move you
go rook before check this is made into
oh you're right boom boom
now with a pawn though you take with the
rook all right you take with the real
good show every single so all okay so
it's not go ahead as you can say I was
just confirming what we were saying
earlier every single non d4 move on the
fourth rank is checkmate exactly and now
we have sort of a detective says you
need to move the rook you need to
maneuver the rope to one of these
squares the problem is it's not as easy
as it seems because if you play rugby
eight right
could you find a way for white to then
put this square under control there's
actually two ways of doing that yeah
upon Andrew exactly 3r okb-1 so each one
of the squares has a problem associated
with it and you need to find the best
relatively best square to maneuver the
rotors so does anything come to mind the
one with my existing rug yes the one on
d8 has to reach one of the squares in
the fourth-ranked the question is which
of the which of the squares is the best
one to try to reach if that makes sense
wait isn't it just gonna be rook rook so
that almost works I thought this was
winning but white has a crazy defense
here why can go rook t3 and paved the
way for the King to go back to d3 and I
did see I did not see that for a long
time so I think the best some of us
probably looked to f8 the idea being if
white does the same thing then you can
transform the advantage you can well if
you move the rook up then it's the same
problem I believe the King back and it's
not me but you can just take the rook
this is similar to what happened in the
game actually and then you take the pawn
and you start mowing down all of his
funds I see I see so that was I think
the best move in this position you gave
him a check which let him off the hook a
little bit he walked right into all of
the remaining checks he should have gone
back probably and he ended up going here
and then he ended up going here so in
this position he should have probably
gone just III probably although here you
give him another check and now he can go
to d2 and attack your Brook and then he
can use the tempo to to say this pawn so
sorry that those areas are all wrong
terrible drawing arrows there we go
does that make sense you have to move
your rook then he goes up three and you
know it's the positions very complicated
you're down upon but you're attacking
his king yeah but only you definitely I
didn't lief L like he screwed up when he
went f3 yeah oh yes that makes sense to
me and then the last thing is the
resulting endgame is actually not as
easy as it appears because there is this
like it's it's very lame
but there is this Russian master I think
that many years ago coined the phrase
all rock end games are drawn I think it
was actually a german german player from
the from the 19th century really all the
rock end games are drawn that's like the
aphorism and what the what the hell does
that mean well if you look into Roccat
games very deeply you'll find that even
positions that look completely winning
have these crazy drawing resources
because the rook can combine its power
to give the King checks in an open board
with its power to support a passed pawn
and it's just very hard to convert these
end games so his best way of defending
this was probably and don't quote me on
this but he probably should have started
pushing his own pawn as quickly as
possible so something like this can we
see what the evaluation is absolutely
I've turned on its so it is yeah it's
nuts it's not going to be zero because
black is the one who holds the defensive
chances it's minus 1.5 which is as I
said somewhere in the in the gray zone
between a wet and a draw so even this
stockfish on chess calm which is pretty
weak it's only reaching a depth of 15 is
not sure whether it's a win or a drop I
think it actually might be a draw with
best play with perfect play yes but
playing this perfectly with white is
virtually impossible that's the other
side of the coin you're not playing
computers you're playing somebody and
white has so many different moves here
it's impossible given the constraints of
a blitz game a rapid game too so you
can't sit and calculate this out for
three hours when do I push the h-bond
when do I give a check it's it's
impossible so that's sort of the rundown
here but you played this perfectly you
brought your King to the right spot you
sheltered it with the rook and the only
thing I would nitpick here and actually
this might still be a move that allows
him to drop this move allows him to drop
again believe it or not and I don't have
to protect the pawn so actually you can
but you could do that while taking his
and maybe now you'll see the idea he
takes your pawn here what do you have oh
yeah I see I see you have a huge blunder
on his part yeah but the thing is if he
ends it's so complicated
exactly
and games are incredibly tactical and
the thing is you might no big deal why
do I need to worry about this pun well
let me show you once he got rooked
before and king eb - what his strategy
should have basically been to give up
his rook at the right moment for your
pawn and then he used his king in the
pawn to basically force you to then give
you a rook up for the pun so what does
that look like he starts with the move
king f5 his idea is to approach g5 in
order to pave the way for the pawn to
start moving okay so you know the pawn I
can't break it very easily
exactly you push your own pond and you
were faster yes but look at this
position your king is in freaking
Timbuktu right now and he's pushing his
own pawn the rook itself is not capable
of stopping the pawn it can only give
itself up for the pond so you can block
it like this but the King's you can
start checking and we're gonna have a
repetition but eventually you're either
gonna have a repetition or you're gonna
have to give up the rope to the pond
boy that's sick like you can force a
draw like that there are beautiful
puzzles in moments from games that
feature this dynamic so King and pawns
against the rook it's a whole category
of theoretical and practical end games
that you have to kind of study to master
the endgame there is no way for a rook
to separate oh I see yeah as long as
they stay like one score next to each
other you cannot separate them and take
the pawn so yeah you're involved and
because I'm too far away it's a
guaranteed draw yes and there's the very
you know when the king is a little bit
closer you start getting absolutely
beautiful tactics that are associated
with this for example a very famous one
and let me I'm gonna artificially
construct it out of this position so
this is not actually what's happening
I'm just I could set up the position but
I'm just I'm just kind of setting it up
manually okay okay so this position with
black to move is it looks like a draw
because it looks like the king is
shouldering off blacks King right and
you're just gonna push the sponsor Queen
but in reality it is winning for black
and this is an incredible concept when
you see it for the first time how is it
winning for black well you start by
giving a check
White's King pushes itself up to g7
intending to play h7 and h8 okay black
goes King g5 and it looks like this is a
lost cause because after age 7 the king
is clearly not fast enough but after
rook a7 checking g8 I'd actually like
you to find blacks move in this position
yep
now it's not the end of the story if I
Queen you obviously affect me checkmate
but White has something very clever that
he can do in this position could you
find it another move
yes white can do something here to stave
off defeat but as we'll talk about only
for one move this is the only like go
right and you lose the pawn checkmate
correct go left you lose the pawn left
lose the pawn anyway for mortgage
checkmate
are you sure about that if you move pawn
you can make something other than a
queen though oh my god yes exactly
you can make a knight but but now King
at night against king and rook in an
open board is a draw that is a
theoretical draw but in this specific
position this is an exception to the
rule because white plays King f6 and
because of this civis my god I cannot
say that word because of the specifics
of the King and knights placement it's a
loss because after King at favor okay
it's checkmate in the knight is boxed in
it is no squares so why doesn't zoom
swamp wow that's insane
and that's thank you John line for this
up and that is one of literally tens of
such theoretical positions that somebody
who masters on games has to know just to
give you a taste of that all my life for
an opportunity we're promoting tonight
is the correct move I actually love on
her promotion so I look for these
chances in all my games I've recently
had a string of games where I've
actually under promoted to a knight and
that was the only way to proceed like
the best one was like a bullet game
again I played against Magnus where I
had to under promote to a knight to
checkmate him but it's very rare it's
very rare
okay but yeah so I am completely at your
service we can take a look at the London
you can play more whatever kind of
floats your boat I'm totally fine do it
oh okay okay
there's this uh there's a style of
practice I wanted to try yeah I did this
with Robert Hess earlier mm-hmm I feel
like it was kind of cool mm-hmm I want
to I want to play a regular match out
mm-hmm but as soon as you feel like the
game is over due to like a blender or
something we swap locations on the board
and I want to see how you would come
back from it
oh that's interesting okay so we play
among us in and out every time or so
though at the moment when I think you
have blundered or you've given the game
away we switch colors yes and then I
want to see how you come back from it
sounds great I'm totally game for that
so do you want white or black do you
want a specific opening or I'll place
the black pieces because I must
experience on it okay sounds good and
I'll probably play 1.e4 because that's
what you'll probably meet in the podcast
everyone plays all right and you see my
moves okay perfect okay is there we can
change your name at the top
unfortunately not that's one of the
features yet you can't I've tried I've
run into that problem before that's like
we could technically do something where
we play a real fake game and then I
invite you to an analysis port on that
game yeah if that makes sense but I
guess it's it's not worth the trouble
yeah it's just fine people who come in
will just be like damn this is the best
thirteen hundred yellow player ever
exactly yeah who is this now max guy
okay so I'm gonna play the fried liver
okay impressive you know the theory it's
it's the only it's the only move by now
oh here I was never sure if Bishop oh
yeah if Bishop out or pawn out was the
correct move its honor its pawn out
because you want to play with tempo
basically and I couldn't even forces
your hand whereas the other one doesn't
yeah and the other one also does I could
actually not tell you straight off to
that why Bishop covering is such a bad
move
so it's not like it's terrible Bishop no
the Bishop to d7 it's it's not the main
move but it's I don't think it's
terrible I just think c6 is like the
theory I say okay and then pawn takes
instead of Knight takes sorry correct
now again you want to play with tempo
push the bishop away and I see now you
have an initiative for the point that's
kind of the rationale behind this whole
line okay
ah but you still want a pawn from me
right so you've sacrificed the point
right and actually this is one of those
lines over where it's hard to see the
compensation because if you look at your
pawn structure it's kind of ruins so you
might be like I not only have they
sacrificed upon what the hell do I get
from and look at my knight on a5 is
place the reality is this knight on d5
is very vulnerable my pieces are not
developed and I'll give you sort of one
hint about playing this position at the
right moment you want to pushy for
potentially if my Knight reaches f3 so
you don't want to let me get air for my
pieces oh but I won't tell you what to
do obviously I'll let you kind of play
this out oh that's a I see so like the
the thing I should know right off the
bat is like I have a I have a six
discovered check on their night
discovered attack discovery yeah exactly
potentially and that's something to
factor in maybe you could just chase the
night away that's also something to
consider yeah and your knight only has
one good square so I want to somehow cut
this square off I like that thinking but
the only way you can cut this square off
is through moving the pawn up now right
but you're right to be skeptical now do
you want me to tell you sort of what the
theory here is give me give me a sec to
see if I can find it sure so why is
moving this pawn not good
I feel like there is a hard-to-find
string that leads to an advantage for
white yeah it's not okay well I can show
you so if you go e for uh-huh which it's
the reason this is perhaps less
instructive for you is because it's a
very logical move there's nothing wrong
with it from a conceptual point of view
you're depriving the end of this square
you want to go age six and that will
force the night to reach this awkward
square where you can pick it off by the
bishop and ruin my pawn structure logic
is ironclad the problem is this pawn is
very weak and in the time that you've
given me I can play the move t3 not only
do I potentially develop my bishop but I
undermine this point and you just don't
have time to play h6 because I'm gonna
take your point so I think that's the
problem you need to switch the order of
these two moves that's kind of a
theoretical continuation I've forced it
to the only good square and then I
attack it bingo
oh okay okay let's continue I'm not
seeing sometimes the glitches where I
stop seeing your moves
did you already play h6 yes crap let me
try to make it synchronize again try
playing h6 again I just did oh no this
is a very famous coms analysis feature
is okay now you see h6 know playing
played six again because it keeps auto
synching it should eventually I am going
to give them so I have already given
them so much crap for this nothing ever
changes Knight up three I see it and I
see you playing me for I'm looking at
your stream and I see you playing e4
there we go perfect okay and I'm gonna
start traveling on a world tour with my
Knights this is interesting
so for me to punish this
and full disclosure this is where my own
theoretical knowledge ends because I
don't play this line personally with a
higher color so I remember it up to here
up to this point I can only generate
sort of logical notes from this point on
yeah I feels like it's not the greatest
position for white to play if your
opponent knows how to respond oh yeah
definitely that's why it's fried liver
is it's a very much risky opening I'm
going to developer castle and attack
your knight at the same time
okay reasonable I'm gonna go d4 to
defend the knight and potentially pave
open the diagonal for my bishop what's
sine I'm kind of scared of being on the
opens and now I do this it didn't seem
like you have any particular threats on
me yellow bright now as will i as will i
okay so now I need to decide if I want
to trade Queens randomly I want to say
no I feel like my queen has a little bit
more potential than yours yeah and also
you're a pawn down so trades unless you
have a very good reason for them are not
create yeah it's not something that you
want to necessarily go out of your way
for especially when you're real down
upon oh right
you you still want a pawn from the in it
from the initial attack correct so let
me think
you win a pawn but what do I get I get
all these like random randomly developed
pieces and now I need to and also open
lines for my periphery yeah exactly open
line so I need to figure out a way to
synchronize my pieces together yes or or
to sort of how do i phrases to undermine
my own pieces before I have finished my
development because notice my own Queen
side if I get my knight in my bishop out
your compensation and initiative is
going to start to evaporate so you need
to operate here with a sense of
particular urgency you don't even have
time to finish your own development
that's the hint I'm gonna give you you
really need to act fast in terms of
undermining my pieces act fast
in terms of undermining your pieces so
to prevent your pieces from going to the
squares you want to go I can't really
cook you can't do that yeah you need to
like identify my most vulnerable piece
here and work on undermining it that's
what I was
feels good it's hot I'll let you choose
a move and then I'll sort of critique
critique it okay I'll just think out
loud so I know you want to get your
bishop out somewhere if I go here I cut
this option off but you can still just
go here which seems totally fine for you
there must be a way for me to stop this
Bishop from providing value I don't want
to trade no I'm not looking to trade I
feel like there's something much better
if I think hard enough about it I I see
here that there's actually there's
actually something kind of interesting
I'm gonna make this move okay that's
interesting actually quite interesting
and I am going to I don't like the way
this Knight is placed so I'm going to
chase it away with my pony right you can
just you can do that I forgot about that
hmm hey chess man yeah so that's you
know and I'm trying to explain the logic
of my own you can take anything fact
that you want to I'm not sure how
exactly won it or we can I wouldn't say
you've made a blunder but you've made
out what I would say is a pretty serious
inaccuracy what if I do this okay now
you've given me a choice of what piece
to take and I am going to take the
bishop I am going to take the bishop
because your bishop was annoying me and
now I'm attacking your knight and now
you have to move the night away okay no
I I said this was this was overall not a
good series of moves can we go back with
you absolutely and we could also switch
colors like however you preferred it so
in this position do you want me to watch
it you're thinking yeah so let me walk
you through the logic first of all the
mood chief I that you were thinking
about in addition to not stopping me
from developing on a3 as he correctly
pointed out do you see the drawback of a
move like this conceptually vulnerable
King very yeah so you're pushing pawns
in front of your king and you're giving
me a hook and I could use this hook in
the future to play a move like f4 and
this is very maka in terms of your king
position I mean here it might take I
mean like real trouble deep yoghurt I
mean I'm gonna take with my bishop this
is gonna be I mean this is just yeah my
sinks great drama teacher used to say
that I've adopted that phrase so you're
not stopping me from developing my
pieces what you need to work on is this
knight on e5 that is the only piece
that's sticking out like a sort of thumb
it looks good but that's like a spy a
Russian spy in America in the 60s right
like as soon as you notice it all of
your forces can conspire against it and
so it is supported very thinly only by
this pawn on c4 right nothing else can
support it well right now right now it's
only supported by this pawn on c4 so I
pathetically let's imagine a scenario
where the spot on g4 were gone this
night would be without a base could you
ensure that this pawn on d4 would be
undermined
oh so I go up here that's the move that
is the move
that is the move and it's it's not
winning it's not that good but it is the
only way I believe to keep the
initiative going because I if I take
your pawn you're gonna take the knight
if I continue with my development as if
everything was fine then you're gonna
take the pawn I can take with the Queen
but you can already tell how vulnerable
this is all becoming right yeah is this
making sense so far not better for me
now and what I would probably do in the
situation is reinforce the pawn with c3
but and this is what you wanted to
achieve initially and you achieved it
indirectly you have now deprived my
knight of a key developing square so
just by establishing this on the board
you have already achieved a lot and in
addition you have cleared away the
diagonal for the bishop so you can
develop your bishop here and you no
longer have the Ponte c6 obstructing
that diagonal whoa so right it's like a
very multi-purpose move so you do it for
one reason but you force your opponent
into inducing these concessions in his
position if that makes sense
yeah well I can understand like why this
move is so great and I'm trying to wrap
my head around the line of thinking that
you had that could bring you to find
these moves right and I hope I've
explained my logic clearly it's not like
I'm you know pulling this move like out
of out of a hat it's just just that I'm
looking at the knight and that's the
only piece that I can fundamentally
really access in this position and I
know that I need to act with a sense of
urgency so we start from these first
principles I need to act with a sense of
urgency if I let white develop these
pieces I am going to be in trouble
therefore I need to do something fast
and from that comes the next step in the
chain of logic which is that it this
Knight is the only piece I can really go
after hmm so when you initially told me
like okay we have a sense of urgency I
don't want to let you develop these
pieces when you told me that I was like
oh that's that's too many constraints
it's not really possible let's just find
like the next best move mm-hmm what I I
feel like there in this case there
happened to be a move but how would you
know if such one exists like
I spent like 30 seconds looking at her I
was like I can't find anything maybe it
doesn't exist and then I just like made
whatever move felt good to me at the
time right but I think you were it's
because you were coming at it from the
perspective of trying to stop me from
developing my pieces rather than from
the perspective of identifying your
opponent's most vulnerable or weakest
piece so I'm gonna give you a tactical
component to this in a conceptual
component tactically you always want to
pay attention to undefended pieces
there's an acronym I could teach you
that will help you do this and that
acronym is LP do or abbreviation LP do
and that stands for loose pieces drop
off and what I mean specifically by a
loose piece is a piece that is not
defended by any pawns okay so a piece
could be defended by another piece and I
still call it an undefended piece or a
piece that's not defended by anything so
most tactics in chess in some way
exploit undefended pieces
okay now fact one here of course this
Knight is it an undefended piece by our
definition it is not right but I'm
trying to make it I've identified a
piece that I could potentially render
undefended and because that radiation is
there any circling in my mind's that
justifies the move c5 I love basically
removing the support behind these pieces
so okay I'm it's really intuitive for me
I can't exactly tell you okay but how
did you think of that in the first place
at some point as well sad is the
subconscious in practice but I've tried
to sort of explain the fundamental logic
behind a move like this makes sense okay
so c5 do you want to make this move and
continue from this point yeah so let me
take I'm not gonna play c3 I'm gonna
play something a little bit more I think
that your opponent's might might do
which is let's say go Bishop to e3 Oh in
place of which move in place of c3 so C
3 would be the best move I'm pretty sure
okay
and might be more reasonable yeah I'm
doing something that I would more likely
expect which is not the best but
something I'd more likely expect from
one of your opponents who are you
playing
are you playing someone tomorrow just
out of curiosity two days okay and who
is your next opponent either pop-up plot
or Swift or I'm no longer I hope it
doesn't come across as too cocky but I'm
pretty sure like I'll be fine for those
mattress I'm mostly just like thinking
about my match against poor boy right no
no that is that is definitely the match
you need to be preparing against all
right so Bishop e3 and black to move
here
[Music]
okay okay
and you've been coming to mind ah I
looked at a couple potential lines none
of them felt that great but I know I
know where I want to attack
I want to attack this rook this row this
area okay interesting I see this hanger
this pawn is hanging yeah I see that if
you move it then there's an open
diagonal interesting that's a good
observation I'm thinking about how I can
like get this okay
I want to pressure this diagonal and
this pawn around the same time I know
that if I move my rock out a player
would just move the pawn up right I want
to first establish the diagonal that's
one thing about winning right now okay
okay so now I'm think about if this
piece is it does this win that for me
well not quite I take with my bishop and
the knight is supportive but now you
should bear in mind and then the night
is by depth by our definition undefended
so the night becomes a lot more
vulnerable once it's once it's lost its
pawn base I have an idea okay I t5 yeah
let's play until I blender and then swap
sides okay okay and I'll just tell you
that that is that is a good move that is
perhaps not the move I would have played
but a good move I'm gonna go a knight c3
okay so I want this guy out all right oh
but I see because you recapture with a
pawn I still can't really break this
chain right this is unfortunately quite
robust this pawn chain which it doesn't
mean your loss sir you're in serious
trouble but it's just that you have to
reorient sort of yourself on two
different set of priorities in this
position yeah
I'm thinking okay so I will now I did I
will ask myself what new week squarest
is upon move create well it does create
once grunts which I can then put my
night oh I was thinking of this one oh I
guess not yet right
oh sorry so what was that I I thought I
didn't even think about this area I was
thinking of something like that right
and I was too actually and I I'm not
ruling that out if you move your night
away from a five I might very well give
you a check on c4 but you were also
attacking my night so now while you
haven't blundered I would say you're
much worse here but you can still keep
what we can play for a couple more moves
before we switch sides I have an idea
yeah well I'm looking at all of the
undefended pieces and I noticed the pawn
on e4 is undefended so I can capture it
whoa Oh awesome with the party maybe
1077 holy smokes ticularly
welcome guys
okay uh I'm I'm thinking about this move
right here
f5 okay so you're attacking my knight I
am going to take the bishop now the
queen is attacking my knight I'm gonna
move it out to a nice outpost again a
square where it's defended by upon back
to its home base okay and whenever I
need whenever I want to attack I need to
remember to attack the squares that are
like I'd attack the beginning of the
chain yes that's that is a good rule to
keep in mind the problem is you're not
really reaching that beginning yeah this
is I'm thinking like this is a great
square for my knight to be if it could
somehow get there safe oh absolutely I
think you could win the roof not here um
what about this okay no no no that is a
blunder yeah yeah baby you you can play
this movie with your switch try it but I
am also attacking your rope wait can't I
attack the weak point of your chain now
um how exactly boom
well yeah that would be the best move
rookie seven evening rookie 7 yeah right
so that is the best move in the position
oh did you later anything oh yeah I just
don't see them it's just it's not
transmitting okay I don't know why it
just flops okay um let's see do you see
me playing it yeah okay all right cool
so basically the reason you're not
technically attacking the pawn is well
my knight is in front of the rock and
the knight is supported and that when I
tell you how important undefended pieces
are this is exactly why it's going to be
very hard for you now to dislodge the
night and if you don't dislodge the
night you're gonna by extension find it
very hard to attack the base of the pawn
chain so mm-hmm
oh my knight can't really ever go here
you can always just trade it even if it
was protected right and you know you
can't really protect that square you're
pointing out with a pawn so it's
maybe in the future you'll be able to
get your night here or you'll be able to
get your night here and trade off the
nights and then your work is gonna start
attacking the base of the pawn chain but
you also and I talked about this a lot
with with Charlie who's a lot weaker
than you but I think it applies all the
way up to GM level the concept of tunnel
vision and tunnels I drew that I Hal I
do that yeah it's it but it refers to a
lot of different things it's obviously
an intuitive concept but it also refers
to you come up with a plan and then you
achieve this plan at all costs and you
fail to realize how even if you have
finally achieved your plan and the
crowning moment comes you've cut the red
tape the ribbon-cutting ceremony has
occurred but then you realize you've
blundered something so let me give you
an example I'm going to make the move C
3 I'm gonna make the move C 3 and I have
actually given you an opportunity here
to trade off the Knights and achieve
your childhood goal of attacking the
base of this pawn chain now you know we
can keep playing this I don't want to
look for students are doing it my way
but obviously that move is gonna be a
trap
that's what I'm trying to show you thank
you for him for this up but we'll talk
about it
I'll let you yeah so this is the move
I'm gonna take tonight bingo now you've
succeeded congratulations you are
attacking III finally you regather got
rid of the knight but do you notice the
position of the queen of the rook that
I've highlighted oh you fork pin yeah oh
yeah yeah
been the queen to the brook a when I win
an exchange or an entire work depending
on what you do and that is the epitome
of tunnel vision where you are only
focused on your successes and you fail
to understand how the position has
changed as a consequence of what you've
accomplished yeah so I didn't like adapt
to the evolving boards day yes and that
is one of the hardest things to do in
just these small detecting small changes
in the position because this is not a
thing that occurs here it's just that
the Queen has moved from d6 to c6 and
all of a sudden this manifests itself
that's a very hard thing to pick up on
and that's just it happens at my level I
do this all the time to just at
different levels of complexity perhaps
so with that in mind I'll shut up les
you're fine let you let you play
and I actually need to run to the
bathroom so you have one more minutes
think about this I'll be right back what
didn't look here on your screen well I
moved it not appear on his screen which
I'm making it again
Oh weird I'm moving my bishop but he
doesn't see it
can you not see this you can't see my
bishop running around
I'm just moving pieces around I'm gonna
see if they appear on his board
can you see these pieces moving you
can't say the pieces moving how do we
get them synched up again where were we
we were right here I'm back whenever
you're ready it's not appearing on your
board yeah let's see I am giving them a
stern talking-to after our session is
always so try again what did I do hair
plate c3 so try to make a move here okay
I see you playing bishop basics on your
stream amazing it's not appearing okay
so Bishop a6 I've made it manually on my
stream that is a good move so you're
trying to straight off your bishops was
that the rationale mm-hmm okay good I'm
gonna take it I take back yeah yeah I
see it
and now I'm going to just do a quick
search for hanging pieces and pawns and
I do identify hanging pawn which I'm
gonna capture I feel like Knight Oh
okay I feel like this is a bad move but
it looks really juicy to me and I want
you tell me why it's bad okay I want to
take I want to take on let me let me ask
you another question so why do you think
it's good I'm looking at getting my
night keeps my arrows yeah I can 90c
poor okay but you realize that you're
sacrificing something right yeah I'm
losing a little bit of a lot so in
exchange and you and you're familiar
with the concept of an exchange that
means just broke for a bishop or Knight
right yes um that is actually you know
that's like making it a fifty thousand
dollar investment into something like
it's it's not insurmountable but it's a
it's worth about two pots so basically
and I don't like reasoning like that
you've sacrificed the equivalent of two
ponds which is not insignificant and let
me explain why is what if you do I see
you played rook you've doubled rooks um
so first of all let me explain why this
is not as good now a good test of of
whether an idea that you think is
tempting is actually good is the okay
there's two Caesarea to talk so much let
me just lay this out really quickly it's
the best case scenario test and the
worst-case scenario test first you ask
yourself if my opponent allows me to
accomplish my greatest childhood dreams
and in your case that's putting your
knight on c4 yes one what specifically
and I mean specifically have you
accomplished with this move what is
going on here in this situation I got a
pawn and I attack your Queen and if your
rook was here I would have attack it too
okay so you're right so let's break that
down you're attacking you said you got a
pawn mm-hmm which one this one okay but
that's only if the rook does no longer
makes contact so I can take your pawn
with my a with my rook and you've taken
your part of my knife big deal okay
we've traded pawns you've sacrificed in
exchange and all you have to show for it
is a knight that looks fancy but what
can you tell me about this Knight which
property does it suffer from that we've
talked about it's loose it's loose do
you see any other loose pieces other
than the Queen that doesn't count
well I guess it does but any other loose
pieces oh I see
my rook bingo is the position your Queen
can go to yes exactly that is a fork now
there is a position your rope gets it to
defend both but because the knight is
unprotected I can just keep attacking
the knight until you lose it so
elsewhere there's nothing I can do here
you can try to defend it again with your
queen but I will attack it again with my
rook and I will evacuate pieces I say I
say okay so basically once you break
down what it is exactly you accomplish
doing all of this just for a pawn is not
a worthy price to pay for the exchange
sacrifice so that's sort of what I call
the bet and all sometimes the best-case
scenario it says can kind of sober you
up a little but you realize that what
you wanted to do is actually not that
impressive now you suggested doubling
the rooks okay now do you again want us
out let me make an empty move here let
me go h3 just for giggles now I want to
move my knight here okay so you want to
go Knight c4 and trade off the Knights
that's much better
unfortunately there is a tactic here
that I could use to win some material
conceptually your idea is perfect now
let me explain what it is the knight is
undefended again I've told you all evil
comes from undefended pieces and you
have an exposed King so you have two
properties the position on defended
Knight exposed to gank can you find a
move for white here that exploits both
of them yes but you can do the same
thing in one move you can you can pin
the knight in one move because if you
really if Pingdom Queen b3 you win the
knight or you win the exchange white
black has to give up his rook and you
take it even with a rope that's a good
idea to trade more pieces off and
because of the pin black is busted huh
so another wove I the way here is even
Queen e2 and now the Queen is undefended
so you see everything stems from
undefended pieces and again I will
either win the knight or I will win the
Queen or I will win the exchange
so that's sort of the fundamental reason
that these undefended pieces are so
important especially when you have an
exposed King in the mix that's like fork
and pin central does that kind of make
sense
yeah that's insane that's so much you
like to keep track of yeah what looked
like a pretty simple game
[Music]